it's been a little while since i've done
a caption contest video if you're not
familiar with what those are i throw up
a picture in my youtube community tab
and say go at it the best 10
or in this case it'll be also a bonus
best of these get to be in the video and
people write things often quite witty or
interesting or sometimes insightful
i picked this photo which is one that i
took a little while ago you can't
actually see this site in milwaukee
right now but that is the miller light
sign
which is on top of a nearby building
and we had some super super high winds
which tore off the old
light sign that was pasted on top of
this and this is what was
underneath uh quite a sight to see so i
took a picture of it
and i wanted to see what people would
have to say so you know predictably
enough a lot of people are familiar with
the miller lore whether it's light or
the miller company itself or the
advertising
so here's the first one
it was miller time once that used to be
a very popular slogan it's miller time
it's time to drink some beer namely
miller the champagne of beers
or some of its spin-offs like light or
miller genuine draft here's another good
one light as air using the spelling of
course
for the brand
and then here's another good one miller
light our sign advertises our flavor so
the sign is all tore up and in bad shape
and that you know is being portrayed as
the flavor and they're not wrong because
miller light is crappy beer it was one
of the early
light beers you know my my mom and a lot
of other people drank it in the 1980s
and you could be guaranteed that your
kids were probably not going to get into
it because it was so watered down and
crappy as a beer as a matter of fact we
drank miller genuine draft when when i
was in high school here's another one a
great taste less filling the same can't
be said for our
sign the sign of course doesn't have a
taste but i guess it's
not less filling meaning that it's more
filling that one doesn't quite make
sense but
it is kind of a funny dig on this
tattered up torn up sign
then we get another one uh not everyone
finds the spirit in the sky
some have to settle for the light and
this was kind of a landmark it used to
be lit up at night with spotlights
and now it's you know it's not looking
quite so good in this picture spirit in
the sky famous song um you know this is
up in the sky as well so those are the
ones that played off of the miller lore
we could say
and then we get a couple other ones that
i have to say
have to do with
inebriation with intoxication so
adam answer says i switched to light
beer so i could get shredded now that's
a great one because the sign is shredded
but a lot of people do in fact drink
light beer because you know less
calories but same amount of alcohol so
or at least more or less the same you
can get yourself blitzed without feeling
quite so
full as a matter of fact you really had
to watch it in college parties not so
much with miller lite but they would buy
you know even cheaper crappier beers
like coors light or
keystone light or busch light and you
know this stuff was so close to water
except of course with alcohol that you
could get yourself pretty drunk and be
pretty hungover the next day
um the next one decay of the inebriator
indeed people drink uh miller light not
really so much for the taste but to get
messed up to get a buzz going on and so
we see this decayed sign which was you
know what was underneath the
previous sign so for years and years
there was this nice
pretty
light sign you know and underneath it it
was all this rot and tatters
now this is a longer one and i'm not
going to read it with g-x mannerisms you
can just substitute the schnift schniff
stuff in there for you
um it says ah for you for here you see
the depreciated state of the miller
light sign
signaling not only the wasteland of
ideology we inhabit but the state of our
being as explained by jacques lacon and
so on and so on so that's got the
zizek shtick we could say down pretty
well
and
you know g-check is all about
commodities ideology that sort of thing
and i think miller kind of fits that
interestingly enough miller used to be
a beer company based here in milwaukee
it long ceased being so when they first
got bought out by sab which was a south
african firm and they really haven't
been i mean they employ people here in
milwaukee but they haven't been a
milwaukee beer
for decades and that gets kind of
concealed by the ideology of you know
commoditization
and
hometown what would we call it beer
pretense
here's two more uh picasso's consumerism
why picasso's consumerism well because
it does
look potentially a little cubist you
know so that fits in
unintentionally
abstract art here's another good take on
it is this art is this found art you
could say it certainly was at one point
in time commercial art but the elements
have not been good to it at least in
terms of that original design but
perhaps they have been good to it
in terms of creating art
and now we come to the final one
from my friend jb who has a whole poem
here right and it's a parody poem just
as much as the zizek thing was parody i
met a traveler from an antique land who
said a vast and lightless sign alone
stands atop a tower near it about the
roof cell towers erupt announcing
nothing and the signs proud boast of
lightness tell that it's marketer well
that the brand did read which yet
survives stamped on lifeless cans the
flavor that mocked all in the watery
drink and in the ads preserved in vhs
miller lite less filling tastes great
it's miller time
nothing besides remains round the decay
of that faded scrofulous sign
peeling and bare the mute and hulking
high-rises stretch
far away so what a little treat we have
here in this poem i wasn't quite
expecting that but i'll certainly take
it and end
on this
now um if you want to get in on caption
contest uh you know check for
pictures posted in the community tab on
my youtube channel if you don't have
your notifications the little bell
turned on you probably want to do that
so you stay on top of
caption contests and anything else
that's going on in my channel and you
can get in on the next one if you would
like to
you